when Kylie Jenner made the cover of
Forbes magazine in 2018 you could say it
caused some controversy it was
everywhere from the New York Times to
NPR even the dictionary weighed in and
when Kylie turned 21
even the bartenders at her birthday bash
wore t-shirts that had her Forbes cover
on it the story was also immortalized in
Travis Scott's Grammy nominated song
Sikkim but the story were telling in
2020 is a little bit different kylie
jenner is super rich and her business is
wildly successful but for years she has
lied and exaggerated just how successful
she really is so let's take a step back
when Kylie's cover debuted in July 2018
our reporter did have some doubts about
the numbers her camp was claiming we
were provided with proof in the form of
tax returns that Kylie herself signed
Plus analysts and industry experts
verified what Kylie's camp was saying
that her business was doing at least 300
million in revenue every year well we
can't prove that those tax returns the
Jenner sent us were fake we're pretty
sure now that they were and regardless
it's clear that for years the Jenner's
had been lying in November Kylie Jenner
agreed to sell 51% of Kylie cosmetics to
Kody that's the beauty giant that Odense
brands like Clara Rommel and Sally
Hansen and the deal valued Kylie's
business at over a billion dollars and
her earnings from the sale are an
estimated 540 million dollars before
taxes but while the deal was great for
her wallet it was maybe not so great for
her reputation because in selling to a
public company details about her
business of come out this sale has laid
bare one of the Jenner family's biggest
secrets which is Kylie cosmetics is not
nearly as big of a business or a
successful of a business as they spent
years leading the entire world including
Forbes to believe the numbers just don't
add up Kylie Jenner's camp led us to
believe that the business had done 360
million in revenue in 2018 in reality
that number was only 125 million
then there's a skincare line they told
us that the skincare line which launched
in May of 2019 had done 100 million in
revenue in just two months
in the reality it hadn't even done 25
million in six months so what does this
mean for Kylie's fortune well first off
it means that she certainly has not been
earning as much money as we had been
estimating in years past based on her
input in part we estimated that Kylie
brought home something like one hundred
and sixty six point five million dollars
in 2018 and one hundred and seventy
million dollars in earnings in 2019 in
actuality was only around 50 million
each year as for Kylie's billionaire
status given these findings and the
impact that the corona virus pandemic is
having on all beauty businesses we think
that she her net worth has fallen below
a billion dollars in other words kylie
jenner is no longer a billionaire every
year we go back and forth with Kylie's
team whether it's about her billionaire
status or if it's about her ranking on
the celebrity 100 and every year they
have something to tell us it's a matter
of great importance to the Jenner's
where we put kylie on these lists this
year was no different at first we
presented all the discrepancies kind of
why were a revenue number so while our
our profit number so off but as we
started to ask more questions about
these discrepancies and the outright
lies in some years the Jenner's did
something that is very out of character
they stopped answering our questions
[Music]
you